boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are still on site in San Jose at
triple-a the American Anthropological
Association Annual Meeting we are now so
grateful to be able to sit down with dr.
Augustine Fuentes hello hi oh that's my
pleasure really excited that the hairs
looking so good right now I can't grow a
hair like that look at this get involved
over there I'm I'm super pumped let me
give a background on Agustin so we have
the program chair for 2017 Triple A
annual meeting professor of anthropology
at University of Notre Dame in Indiana
since about 2002 ish but so he did a PhD
at Berkeley and anthropology and he's
done things everything from chasing
monkeys and jungles and cities to
exploring the lives of evolutionary
ancestors to examining what people
actually do across the globe and he's
authored six six books 14 edited volumes
150 papers there's a chapter something
like something like there's a lot of a
lot of it's a lot of work and everything
from misconceptions about human nature
specifically in the areas of race sex
and aggression to creative spark how
imagination made humans exceptional
we'll be talking about a bunch of these
different things now but before we you
know go into all the current stuff you
know who were you as a kid and how did
you pick up anthropology so when I was a
kid I didn't know anthropology existed I
like stuff right I like I like the past
I like the present I love trying to
figure out what makes us tick what makes
us what makes other animals I've always
really been excited about that and I
remember getting to college sitting in a
class a college classroom which it
turned out was an anthro class and they
were sort of generally going over what
we're gonna do and I thought wait this
is a thing that there's actually
something that touches on sort of humans
the past the future the president other
animals all connected it's like okay
yeah I think I could do this what was
the I guess you know where did they get
where where did that happen
where was the well I mean so there's a
lot of different things that have
happened over the course of my life I've
always been interested in asking
questions I'm really to the point of
being really annoying I'm interested in
how stuff works and I'm particularly
interested in how humans work and why
humans work and how we can talk about
them what does that mean for us right so
by the time I got to college I was
really excited I was gonna double major
in theater and biology and it turns out
they don't like it when you mix science
in humanities so they're like no no he
can't do that but and then I had heard
about you know some anthro classes and I
remember sitting in an anthro class from
the professor
Phyllis Dolan who would eventually be my
graduate advisor and I'm sitting there
and is a class on primate behavior and
she starts lecturing and talking about
this chimpanzee or this Langer and she's
using the pronoun sheet again and again
referring to these monkeys and aids and
it dawned on me I'd never heard a
professor use the pronoun she' in
general sense when talking like what's
going on here this is pushing against
what I you know usually hear and the
more I got into anthropology the more I
understood that asking questions about
who we are in a deep sense and what we
do in a deep sense really is exciting I
would love to help get that those these
questions and the whys of the deep sense
to the roots of children being born
around the world yeah I think that's
gonna get us to some good question
asking and some good kind of inquisitive
spirit about how to best build an
engineered the world moving forward okay
so I can totally see with your energy
just like wanting and like ask questions
and I can see how you also got really
excited about about anthropology so now
okay so now as you know what was what
was was was there a link between between
that moment and about primates
especially and then your interest in
that and
I mean I think if he asked this or a big
picture what what clicked right what
clicked for me was because I've always
been interested in biology the body
right and I've always so been religious
in behavior and culture and literature
and history and to see that there was a
space here where you could link the
biology the bones that the muscles the
guts the DNA to our behavior to the way
we are in the world to our closest
relatives the primates but yet not
detach that from history in institutions
and politics and power to actually try
to mix all those things together I was
like oh yeah this is what I want to do I
started by being really interested in
the other primates because to understand
what humans are we have to understand
where we sit in this sort of broader
world right we are primates so
understanding what other monkeys and
apes do and what we share with them and
what we don't share with them really
sets this baseline so I became very
interested not only in studying the
human but sending the human is part of
the primate landscape to start with and
then I move forward to focus more on the
human but to start with you got to know
what you're comparing let's let's talk
about that what did you learn as you
were figuring out the comparison so what
I learned really quickly and this is
from I've spent now decades studying
other primates monkeys and apes in a in
the field and in captivity and in
captivity so what did I really learn
well that humans think a lot of
themselves a lot of the stuff that we
think is totally human that's actually
primate the strong social connections
the role of social networks and
connectivity the whole reality that our
lives are just multi-layered complex
social day-to-day interfaces with all of
these different individuals that have
different personalities and different
ways of being
that's primate yeah right now humans put
a special twist on but to understand
that was actually liberating and
challenging at the same time liberating
because it's like okay we can actually
understand a lot about the human
experience by studying broadly but then
we have to focus down because evolution
is about continuities and
discontinuities and so the continuity is
between us and the other primates are
critical and understanding the core the
base of what humans are or can be
but the discontinuities
the last bit of our evolution that
trajectory in humans is what's most
exciting because that shows us what the
capacity of minutes yeah cuz it's just
what is it less than one percent
genetically different yeah I mean that
we have to be careful though so like
yeah we shared you know 98.6 or whatever
98% of our DNA with a chimpanzee we also
share 37% with a daffodil right what
does that mean what's really important
is to sort of evolutionary commonalities
so you know about eight to ten million
years ago the human lineage and the
chimp and other ape lineages sort of
split out and sort of went their ways
now doesn't mean we stopped influencing
one another and we're messing with
chimps horribly right now but what it
means is that for the last six seven
eight nine million years our
evolutionary trajectories have been
particular relative to everything else
and it's that particular history it's
really interesting okay okay
yeah the particularity rather than the
necessary necessity to talk about the
specific right right right right so I
mean those are genetic differences but
people overplay what that means or
doesn't mean right so all humans are
99.9 percent identical genetically yeah
right that's cool but what's your
particular trajectory Ray's mine and
it's not be completely for lives exactly
exactly and it's not just about our DNA
right it's never just about our DNA DNA
does nothing by itself and there's
definitely too much time talking about
DNA how you behave in an environment
yeah what yeah so because I specifically
reference that point about the DNA
difference just because it's interesting
because of the what would it look like
for one more right of augmentation
evolution because we got two celestial
bodies it's like where do we go the next
one well I think there's something
interesting in this whole giant panoply
of life right like if we would just take
that let's just take the the sort of
genetic diversity of the planet or
whatever humans are this little teeny
teeny sort of insignificant like in in
the sense of what genomic diversity
looks like across all living things
however when you talk about what humans
are doing for the planet and doing to
each other and doing to everything else
we're huge that's the question right so
the real exciting thing about
understanding the human and human
evolution is how
how did that happen what's going on why
are humans so important so amazing and
so horrible all at the same time so
we're one of I think ten million species
right and yeah weird but we're by far at
the top of the well chain I don't know
where the top
we're definitely messing with the whole
system we are yeah we're now we figured
out we are stewards of earth I mean you
have to figure out how to do that
properly birth out of this womb and go
out into the space yeah so I want I want
to ask you about the problem I want to
get a little bit Newton into the nuance
of the primate primate studies the way
you explain social networks there's been
a lot of videos that are now being
released about how kind of like in many
ways there's like alpha chimps yeah and
so there's like you know there's people
here that have succeeded in many ways
how did they succeed or people out in
the business world whatever so you have
what is your sort of after your photos
so yeah this is a great topic because I
think there's a misrepresented all the
time we have all these this notion about
dominance hierarchies space there's an
alpha and then you know on top and it's
almost an alpha always a male right
alpha male the male wolf but even though
frequently the alphas female but let's
break that down from oh what does that
really mean
this actually whole idea of these
dominance hierarchies comes from this
idea of priority of access to resources
so you know you put a peanut in the
middle of four monkeys three you can be
like I'm not touching it that guy it's
gonna get it that guy will come and take
it
right like oh that's the Alpha what
we're really seeing is this complex set
of relationships of histories of
personal dynamics we're not seeing some
endemic genetic component that makes one
alpha another not so what we're really
seeing we talk about Dom dominance
hierarchies we're seeing really
complicated social realities that change
over time we don't talk about it that
way we tend to think about well if
there's the high ranking there's the low
ranking it's like that stuff switches
that stuff moves around and it's all
contingent it's all dependent upon there
they're growing up and who they hung out
with and who their friends were and what
your opportunities they had or didn't
have that's true for humans is true for
chimpanzees and then what was the word
you used you said and it was like access
to resources yeah yeah yeah yeah I
already have access to resources
resources is depend
on your hire cope position or your
relationships or your history so for
example in macaque monkeys there are
pretty clear dominance hierarchies for
many of the different species and so
like a high-ranking male will come by
and get access to the food right others
won't even bother but in some cases that
high-ranking male will be around and
then this one female who has three
offspring that male come up and that
male won't do anything as long as that
female is around and those offspring
outrank the adult male hmm social
dependence context and it's all about
social relationships and histories and
experience so dominance is not something
inherent of an individual right it's a
process it's a pattern and we have to
remember that because we think we tend
to think well this is a type-a
personality or this is a dominant male
it's like well why how where when it's
not in his genes mm-hmm it's so cool
when you talk about going out into the
field and seeing the behaviors first and
then being able to see how we the we're
very hubristic in many ways and so when
you look at chimps you kind of get that
Oh like I get it I get where we evolved
from right now
when did how does this relate with your
current professing because do you are
you are you teaching these types of of
teachings to students are they coming
out sometimes with you to the field you
still go out to the field what are you
teaching students whatever it some cool
realizations of teaching for you so I
mean I think there's a lot of things so
you know a lot of my work is looking at
the other primates is also located human
biology it's also looking at the way in
which we conceive of and think about
human nature what does it mean to be
human right whether it comes sex
aggression gender racism all that kind
of stuff it's funny though because going
into the field to watch non-human
primates watch macaque monkeys for
example in the field gives humans the
students in this case you saw under the
human privates yes so oh yeah I mean I'd
like to use other primates that most
people say non-human primates just
because to remind it that's the monkeys
these are the humans were both primates
yeah you've got humans you got primate
you got monkeys both the primates what's
amazing about taking students into the
field right in this context
is that they're forced to sit and watch
other complex social mammals hang out be
with each other sort of live their lives
and and they can reflect even if
subconsciously on our own experience in
the way in which we are even more
complex than that but watching monkeys
is humbling because a lot of the stuff
that we think we're all we're so smart
we're socially dense you know humans do
all this stuff so do a lot of other
organisms right and so we got to step
back a little bit just because we can
destroy a rainforest doesn't mean we
know how to get along better than all of
those things living in the rainforest
and so taking students into the field is
a great way to sort of show them what
does the world look like how does the
world behave and then they can bring
that back in the classroom in the
classroom I try to do that with
information about human biology about
human history and about human society
right so mixing together all of these
different data from ranges of
anthropological biological sociological
and historical sources to sort of bring
them together and offer a little bit of
a glimpse of what does reality look like
it's always messy it's always entangled
it's always calm you know complicated
but that's awesome
and if we can convey that in
anthropology in the classroom and we
have the opportunity more than anyone
else if we can convey that we're gonna
prepare those students no matter what
they go on to do with this skill set
right they'll know it's complicated but
they'll be able to say something about
that complexity yes and there's this
process of just being mindful when you
are in the field and I really I'm just
so fascinated by fieldwork now okay no
no what what is give us an example of
when you connect in the biological and
the cultural ties into fieldwork when
they come back how yeah what does that
look like well so let's think some of
the work I've been doing for the last
couple decades is particularly in this
area of called ethno primatology right
so it's thinking about humans and other
primates entangled in ecology zko
constructing their relationships in
different places at the planet I've done
a lot of work in Bali many years ago
looking at macaque monkeys humans
Balinese Hinduism temples forests rivers
tourism all of these things connected
gather and they kind of cohabitate yes
they co-create each other they Co they
shape those interfaces whether we're
talking about you know sharing the same
space we'll talk about the economic
input from tourists who come to see
monkeys for the local villages or
whether we're talking about the
potential exchange of bacteria and
viruses all of those levels and so when
you when you think about this from a
medical in an Apple article context when
you ask students to sort of reflect on
this it's that crazy mesh of reality
that acts to inspire the students to
think that they can take this
information and go somewhere else maybe
some of the students who work with me
where I know some students are working
me on monkeys and humans and interfaces
it were gone on to do all sorts of
different things but in their new lives
in their new worlds they're like well I
understand these things were all related
they're entangled they're pushing and
pulling on each other and in
anthropology one of our underlying goals
or what we say is we want to make the
familiar strange and the strange
familiar and once you break this bubble
of well everything is the way I just
lived and realize there are many many
successful ways to be human or to be
primate all of a sudden the world opens
up a little bit to more possibility and
more hope even in times of great tragedy
yeah I love how how you said that make
the familiar strange the strange
familiar that's really important and
just this is inherently a very
multidisciplinary field so that that and
our show is as well so when I want to
hear you talk about augmenting the
perception of students see things as
multidisciplinary that's fascinating
obviously and give us your kind of like
your some of your most profound
realizations of dealing with students or
with teaching students what have been
some of your favorites well I think I
think I mean there's a couple things
that just jump out I think one of the
most important things is teaching
students is a great humbling experience
right because even in in in the classes
that haven't been great you can see
those sparks right that that potential
of there's aha moments yeah that this
desire to know what's going on how this
stuff work even in the most blase
students every now and then you hook
them with something interesting and and
all of a sudden it's there
and that that always gives me great
confidence that is messed up as the
world is and is getting there are so
many people a majority of people want to
do something good in the world they want
to figure it out and teaching actually
constantly reinforces that because if
you do a decent job if you open the
space for the students to be the co
producers of knowledge stuff happens
stuff gets done that's exciting so
that's that's one I think it's a park in
the eyes of the students to learn and to
build value into the world exactly and
and another thing is that by teaching I
learned I know that's a trite phrase
people say this all the time but I can't
tell you every time I step into the
classroom every time I start a lecture
or workshop or some sort of engagement
it's material I know I wrote the stuff
maybe Ivan wrote the book we're using
and here I'm going along and someone
said something or someone introduces a
perspective or someone just raises their
hand and asked me to slow down and sort
of re-exploring sore I didn't see how
this relates and so constantly being
pushed by students and graduate students
in particular or great because they're
like you know junior colleagues in the
sense that they have so much knowledge
and so much excitement they don't have
the experience that you do but they push
in really amazing ways and so it's those
mind-blowing events right and that's
like hanging out with friends right or
family or sometimes you sit there it's
when someone's just like well what why
is that and pushes you a little bit
that's when you get really that's when
you learn right complacency is the worst
thing that can happen right and and in a
good classroom there's no complacency
because you're constantly getting pushed
I love that is it's so true when you're
asked a question by like a junior
colleague and then you gain a new sense
of seeing things because they're
teaching you right that's that's really
that's really even teaching you what's
important now right I mean it would be
horrible if we were all in these like
age cohorts never being able to talk
across ages right we wouldn't know what
was going on because you heard they grew
up with the computers and this so
they've had a different axe
today the abundance of information
they're rightfully right the whole way
and just and all every sort of
generation has the different experiences
their different lives and by listening
to them you know we get enriched and
they by listening to us yeah totally
it's that the intergenerational wisdom
feminine have an integration wisdom and
I'm part of this big project called the
evolution of wisdom work no philosophers
theologians humanists anthropologists
biologists it's a this whole notion that
there is something out there that we can
think of his wisdom that yes a satirist
discern and do do right in the world as
best you can
yeah it's a really cool concept and I
wouldn't even have thought about it
given my training until I was
interacting with philosophers and
theologians and literary folk they
pushed me to think well you know can we
think about this in a way that makes
sense outside of just biology or outside
of just an ethnographic context yeah and
in the hundred billion people that built
civilization they would want us to
retain some sort of an essence the
essentials of wisdom that that can be
passed on I can't I mean I could be
totally wrong but this is what I believe
that you know a couple million years ago
our deep ancestors right and in Eastern
Africa or maybe even southern Africa
were developing this incredible capacity
to see a stone and in that stone to see
something else to see a tool to see a
change and reshaping that we creating
that and sharing that not just
individually right but sharing that with
the young and the old and working
together to sort of craft something this
kind of creativity and collaboration and
I would like to think that we have
inherited it down all that time we are
constantly doing it we're working with
iPhones now instead of stone tools but
it's the same compassionate is this this
I this capacity to imagine to create to
collaborate what I think being human is
is to look at the world see what's
around us see what is imagine
alternative possibilities and to get
together as a group and try to make
those things reality
that's so well said that's so well said
yeah but this is ant deposits right
anthropology offers this insight because
it forces you not to just say what's
this reason or it's that reason or
single cause it's all about this complex
mass and that sort out the public off
tain't apology because you know at the
biologist of famous for saying oh it's
complicated but it's complicated doesn't
mean we can't talk about it
we can't know about it we can't learn it
we just have to figure out how to best
convey that complexity in its wonderous
you know reality and I think you just
did it did it right there with the
contrast you gave a contrast something
that's super relatable today of using an
iPhone and building apps and
collaborating on that and then using a
stone tool seeing a rock and making it
into a stone tool that can be used for
that that that that is so I connected
man and I and I kinda and I kind of did
a similar thing where I was very
recently writing about just what it
would have been like to you know look at
the moon and worship the moon and
whatnot and then now we have rockets
that go to so it's just this yeah but we
haven't lost that on wandering right so
I was flying in last night from Boston
late night right you like went and I
crazy so anyways I came back some flying
in doing horrible things for the planet
by flying too much but that's a whole
nother thing so I'm flying in and I'm
sitting on the ILC but the windows open
and the airplane is about to land here
in San Francisco nat banks and and I see
this slit like a Halfmoon shining
brilliant but a little bit the smoke is
making a little bit red so not quite a
Blood Moon but you know just sort of
that look and I look at that and in that
moment I shared everything across
millennia of that wonder for the moon
even though we've sent people there and
landed there it doesn't in any way shape
or form change that aw and wonder and I
think that's that's the ticket and how
do we get is it important to get seven
and a half billion people to when they
look at the moon to get them to be more
aw and have more wonder is to have that
sense of they all have that capacity if
the capacity we beat it out of them as
they grow up you know we we've we've
taken this incredible what I call the
creative spark this incredible capacity
for creativity and imagination in
humanity and many societies ours in
particular tries to grind that out of
people to become functional become
practical right we can do great things
and still have on wonder we can be
playful and imaginary and creative and
still produce on a regular basis I think
we have to be very careful every human
alive has the capacity for awe and
wonder and yet most humans because of
inequality because of political
oppression because of other contexts
aren't able to even find the time to do
it whereas others have been had it
trained out of themselves and that's
that's what scares me
let's this is the newest book this is
your my last book I have a new book
coming out next year but your last book
was the creator spark combination made
humans exceptional and and this is kind
of what we're what we're talking about
right now is that the imagination of the
rock the imagination of the phone that
the imagination to get to that place has
in that collaborative spirit to get
there so so tell us I mean tell us a bit
about that but also some of these other
you know I really also want to talk
about the misconceptions human nature
race sex and aggression so let's just
bust this down clearly right so this
concept of human nature is wrong let us
say human nature's if you're really
interested in that there are many
successful ways to be human period we
know that the data are in there's just a
huge diversity of ways to do the human
thing well so let's let's put that aside
right human nature human nature I think
that's the way it is the problem is many
people think that there's some core
usually some sort of genetic or
biological core for the complexity of
those nature's right and and and
obviously everything has a biological
facet work organisms for organic
creatures right but we're never
disentangled let me give those three
examples right race sex and aggression
right so many people despite what they
might say believe that black white Asian
Latino Native American what-have-you or
biologically identifiable clusters they
are not
Yeah right this is very says we use it
is not reflective of a biological unit
however it is a very real lived
experience when we say race is a social
construct we don't mean it's fake we
mean it's totally real it's just we made
it up and and imposed it on the world
and because of racism right what race
you happen to embody or be classified in
can have deleterious biological social
political historical experience allowed
comes that's what's really important
none of this is in our nature right it
is in our histories or institutions or
cultures human biological diversity is
incredible humans vary in skin color and
height and shape and by multiple local
populations around the planet
none of that fits into African European
Asia those races are not biological
units but there sure are real things in
people's minds and so I think one of the
things to push against is to say well
what do we know about race and racism
and those two always have to be together
right because race is prominent because
of racism and so that's one example
right it's there's no gene for black
white or Asian but there's a lot of
institutional political and economic
infrastructure for black white and Asian
that's one example to look at it yeah so
the sex thing the sex thing in a let's
take sex and gender right you know
gender is that the lived experience
dynamic embodiment in a cultural context
of sex and sexuality sex in the most
specific context is about biology so we
tend to identify male and female that is
in mammals right females right tend to
give birth and lactate males don't but
if we actually break down the biology we
find that it's pretty complicated
there's a whole range of things that we
associate as male or female they're not
two separate things it's the same
species it's a biological continuum and
humans fall along that continuum again
there are many successful ways to be
human so we talk about human nature's
right we can't say there's a male nature
and a female nature those are
nonsensical statements what we can say
is different cultures institutions
histories and bodies
map to this diversity of a way of being
gendered and sexed in the world so
that's really important because if if we
just use that as our starting point not
that male men are from Mars and women
from Venus if we use this sort of
diversity of successful ways to be sex
and gendered then people have a lot less
problem fitting in in a society because
right now we're trying to cram everyone
into two little cubby holes and you know
what the vast majority of us cannot fit
in either of those spaces not perfectly
yeah so that's that's really good and
then you know the thing on aggression I
think that's really important in this
day and age because we have this whole
notion deep from our sort of Western
political philosophical histories of
this this demon inside us this
horribleness particularly in men right
this sort of original sin if you will of
violence and aggression that humans are
demonic males and we tend to think that
warfare aggression violence cruelty
seemed to be at the heart of what it
means to be human
if you look at the fossil and
archaeological record if you look at the
other primates we find that no what is
characteristic of primates what's
characteristic humans strong social
bonding social complexity the potential
for great violence and aggression but
the reality that compassion and working
together collaborating is probably at
least as if not more common than
aggression so peace and war are not
opposites they're all part of the same
capacity we have for getting together
for bonding for making stuff happen
sometimes it has horrible outcomes there
other times it doesn't but there's no
naturalness to a super aggressor if that
was the case we wouldn't be here you
know
yeah 2 million years ago we were small
naked bang less hornless clawless
critters right with some rocks and some
sticks and all of these giant predators
out there and all these challenges yeah
what do we have we had each other that's
actually really well yeah I think that's
really evident in human bodies and in
human biology and the human Paylor
anthropological and archaeological
record that doesn't mean that we didn't
run around hitting each other in the
head too
yeah but that's just not our go to right
now aggression is not the human nature
whoa the the that was that was really
profound at the end when he said that
when we were so naked and raw in our in
our you know nascent stages of being
human that we were that we had each
other that was what I was really
profound I want to see if I can if I can
give a let's see if I if I got this
right so with so with race there is a
we're all human we're all one range of
human race diamond race looking from the
moon we're all human race and then
biological biologically right and then
the and then the the says it's become a
we've made the societal we said societal
differences historical political social
structures right we're gonna divide this
cluster here this cluster here discussed
here and we're gonna call them things
they're real things right yeah those
divisions are real in the sense that
they're created they have history they
have institutions they have impacts but
they're not biology
yeah they're not some evolutionary
trajectory who didn't have three groups
of humans who branch exactly with
different colors right or braudys or
whatever it's so race is real but it's
not biology and then there is now to
move on to to to gender serve sex sex to
move on to sex then there is a kind of
it's not it's not a species split but
then there's a male and a female that
make it so that you can have a
procreation and a child yeah I mean
there's there's biology of reproduction
by IG reproduction but then there's a
continuum of ways to express being human
these human rights right yeah okay and
so what we would call like where do you
draw the line between male and female
right biologically speaking it's
arbitrary
right it's like drawing line between
Europe and Asia what you do we we don't
have a line we just say well that's
these mountains right these are
Europeans these are Asians that doesn't
and then we say well this is masculine
or this is feminine we make up those
decisions the human spreads across the
whole place and then there are certain
things like ocean the Big Five
personality and so you can make a proxy
assessments of psychometrics and whatnot
totally and so and then in there you
know like what's classified as feminine
in one society might not be classified
wholly as feminine or another and what's
interesting what's classified feminism
askin may not map to the sex body that's
right right they may be you know yet the
sex body might move around between all
of those gendered concepts now you see a
whole movement for males to be more
vulnerable women want to take on more
work or career roles in that sense and
and they always did right I mean that
the thing is that gender roles are fluid
and they're historically variable right
so the way we are right now
it's not necessarily where the were we
were in the past nor will it be in the
future but it is the way we are right
now so we got to deal with that sort of
think about what does that mean what it
does mean is that we're malleable we're
open to change and and I'm and I'm
always very interested in what the next
evolutions of civilization are and if
humans because I do think there is
something to do with this the way that
we use technology and how that's
affecting our brains and where that's
taking us and then also to have the
singularity do transhumanism right all
that kind of stuff so there is gonna be
this next evolution and then just the
way that you know even with
neurodiversity the way that some
children are being born into not wanting
to have social engagements but wanting
to just go really deep into learning
about something and so if that's the
case who are we to pull people away from
that thing and wrap them towards other
things and neurodiversity is actually
that's one of the new frontiers right
yeah won't we now that we're realizing
oops wait there is no normal there's
just a whole range of being human and
understanding that is actually be
critical for educational policy yeah
right for what our future societies look
like there's a whole bunch of other
diversity that that we already know
about that we still have trouble dealing
with man nuru diversities can be the
heart it's gonna be really hard for
people to deal with yeah and then that
then the last point dish made about
aggression was was quite interesting
that that I really enjoyed thinking
about just the cooperation that we've
had over time
to build what we have and cooperation
doesn't mean lack of aggression right
like who who wins the battle right the
army that's most aggressive or the
awkward army that cooperates best no
army they do operates best the army that
is strongly bonded right and so like the
Sparta yeah yeah yeah I mean that's
what's actually really important people
try to do peace and violence as
opposites they're not they're just
humans do cooperation really really well
so when we do it for really violent
cruel things we do it better than
anything else but we have the capacity
to do that at the same time we're the
capacity for incredible peace for
incredible compassion and that is just
as if not more common in our histories
than the violence pasady you know so
Trott stop saying that they're opposites
and talk about them as capacities and
what do we do with capacities we modify
them we exploit them we engage with them
let's think seriously about this stuff
what's the lie about monogamy
so I mean here's the big problem
monogamy is a particular historical
concept about marriage practice right so
monogamy in the in the reproductive
biology is that one part two partners
stay together for one mating season or
longer exclusively it's actually very
rare in in in mating season yeah well
even a mating sees it right so many many
organisms don't do that right most
organisms are polygamous in the sense
they move around and have multiple
mating partners right so do humans we
have social structural cultural
historical norms and expectations about
reproductive relationships and we've
codified those in marriage contracts or
different kinds of things and so
monogamy as a political philosophical
orientation who's got all mixed up with
the biology no separate those two
there's no putting there's no rings on
our chips there's no right no but
there's these incredible relationships
between individuals yeah sometimes
there's a social bond do they have a
lifelong Oh many do sometimes they have
sex sometimes they don't so that's the
thing is when we think about pair bonds
bonds between two individuals that are
very very strong those can go for a
lifetime
the
might have nothing to do with
reproduction yeah they must worry about
all sorts of others that's right and
it's the same for humans and we could
have you know - humans could be very
very tightly bonded in a reproductive
context but it doesn't mean they don't
find interest in having sex with other
as I said that that conflation was sex
reproduction social bonding you know
those are actually all different things
they all come together in certain
contexts but if we try to pretend that
they're all the same and like if
everyone is spending their whole life
trying to find their you know soul mate
you know that's a problem
find soul partners buying the social
partners social find bond spa hang out
and make connections and not and not
always will those bonds be sexual and
exactly sometimes they'll be for a year
sometimes they'll be for seven years
rights or whatever right um but that
that weird expectation that like oh boom
you know find one and done
that's a weird concept not that it
doesn't happen a lot yes yes but it
works for certain people but it is not
we can't think again back to this human
nature right what do humans use we're
messy
we're complicated and we're social get
over it yeah wow this has been so
enlightening awesome and I guess just to
wrap it up I'd love to hear some of your
your synthesis about like what you see
as the current state of humanity and
where we're going
right I mean so my the two things one is
general humanity right our species Homo
sapiens sapiens right
I love humans I'm incredibly optimistic
about human potential and human capacity
everything I know about human biology
about our deep history about our recent
history and about our present inspires
me to see what humans can do right for
good and for worse so I'm optimistic
about humanity what I'm not optimistic
about is our contemporary political
economic and social landscapes I think
there's a degree of cruelty and a degree
of inequality that is just unsustainable
and so I'm really worried about the
immediate future because of inequality
because of racism because of sexism and
because of a kind of institutional bias
that who rips people apart
and while humans have great potential
fighting against these inequalities and
in justices is pushing us to our limit
so I am worried about that and what
would be a solution that you well we got
a ramp down in it there's wherever you
can get rid of any inequality that's
always here to stay now given our
systems and our histories but we can
ramp it down
education oh and I and I and I thought
I've started proposing this on the show
now that here's the top ses in the world
is the lowest SES in the world it's just
that if everybody can move up at the
same time and then I just bring the
lowest SES up closer yeah yeah something
yeah yeah well I mean what you do is
shave a little bit off like you know you
can anyway so that's a whole economic
argument yes reducing inequality I think
that's critical but also education is a
great way to do that so let's reinvest
in our schools
let's make teaching matter let's make
learning matter but really really care
about kids I think that's right now I
get the impression that most people
don't they don't care about kids in the
in the environment they don't care about
kids in school they don't care about
kids in health not really if we cared
more about kids who'd probably get a
little bit further along the route road
to making the world better and reducing
inequality yeah
and we were mentioning that earlier in
the conversation as well just as deep
care for augmenting the perception of
children to understand like the contrast
that you were making before about where
society was and where we are now that we
had the stone and we made it into tools
and now we have a technology like
computers and I make that into tools
what's that apps and the things that we
use them but it's all social it's all
creative and it's how we use it right I
mean we could use that stone tool to
knock someone over the head or we could
use it to work together to build more
stone tools to teach others and to go
skin a critter or dig up a root or
something like this yes we have that
choice yes yes this has been so
fascinating I'm I'm deeply grateful that
you joined us I always love having this
opportunity to chat thanks thank you
thanks for coming on the show of hugely
appreciated my friend appreciated them
please check out the links in the bio
for a triple-a and for Augustine's work
also do give us your comments we'd love
to hear from you about the episode which
you all thought go and manifest your
dreams in the world go and build the
future everyone thanks much love
we'll see you soon right wow that was so
fun
that's a great concept would grow fun
interview man I'm glad you had a good
time